i've done seven
tour lectures so far and
with an average audience size of about
2500 and
they're going great they're unbelievably
positive everybody almost everybody
dresses up which i think is really cool
really yeah well when i went on tour in
before i went out i thought i wanted to
do this like 100 right or at least as
close to that as i could manage so i
went out and bought
some expensive suits and i spent way
more money on this is one of them
actually you look great by the way thank
you thank you way more money than i ever
thought i'd spend on clothes and i
really felt quite bad about it you know
i thought maybe it was an extravagance
but i thought no way man i'm going to
see if i can nail this dead on and i'm
going to be speaking to you know 100 000
people i'm going to
look as sharp as i possibly can
and
one of the consequences of that has been
that
young men in particular come to the
lecture tour dressed up in suits
three-piece suits they're when the
couples come and they're dressed up like
they're coming to a wedding or
so that's really something and why do
you think that is why is it because you
said that they're sick acting like kids
okay you know our whole culture pushes
the idea that teenage
life or even childhood for that matter
but teenage life is some sort of
pinnacle and then everybody dresses down
so they look especially men they look
like overgrown 10 year olds and there's
something extremely demeaning about that
and so to provide people with
opportunity to
dress up in a in a classic manner and to
look like adults to present themselves
in that manner
there's something very attractive about
that because we haven't done that in our
culture that's been
i would say
downplayed in importance or
or or
for
certainly since the 1960s who's to blame
for that because you recall anytime you
would fly in an airplane if you see old
school pictures people were dressed in
three piece suits to go on an airplane
this is in the 60s i assume and then now
you see someone like mark zuckerberg
wear a t-shirt to give a speech in front
of a ted talk or something like that so
still
some of it's just fashion you know i
mean fashion moves around and then
and it's it usually drifts from the top
down and so when formality becomes the
norm but that drifts down to say to the
working class then the upper class
thinks well we can't do that because
that would you know associate us with
the unfashionable people and then they
dress down and so then that drifts down
the hierarchy and so there's some of
that some of it's just fashion but a lot
of it too is this
idea that
this sort of
reflexive rebellious attitude that
anything that violates traditional norms
or even anything that's associated with
patriarchal oppression and adulthood is
to be
eliminated in favor of what's
hypothetically a more free individuality
but it's not because everybody looks the
same i was in washington
four or five years ago maybe longer than
that it's probably longer than that when
i first went in the summer and one of
the things that really struck me all
these people wandering around these
great monuments is all the men looked
like overgrown 10 year olds they looked
exactly like their kids except they were
bigger they looked like they'd been
inflated with a bicycle pump and i
thought this is weird that
that adults are addressing like children
and
not good and so some of it's fashion but
some of it's also that is it exclusive
in america how about in canada what have
you seen all over the world with this no
i don't think it's exclusive to america
i think it it was more noticeable to me
in washington and
i think that's when it really hit me
because washington has in some sense a
place of pilgrimage and people from
every class go there and that's that's a
good thing and and they should from
every economic class and so it was like
a cross it was a real cross-section of
the total population and that was one of
the things that struck me quite quite
bluntly and so anyways it's very nice to
see all these people dressed up and when
you hear the argument being made it's
the following argument the argument is
look
uh
you you you only have so much energy to
make so many decisions throughout your
day do you want to be in front of the
closet in the morning picking and
choosing what suit i'm going to wear to
tie with what shirt and what tie you
know what i'd much rather not
consume my energy thinking about what
outfit to put together it's a lot easier
to just have a white shirt
jeans and regular tennis shoes and go to
work and let me make the bigger
decisions while i'm running the company
i've never felt bad not wearing a suit
every time i've had a suit on i felt
better than just walking out with a
t-shirt on even though the t-shirt is a
lot
easier to do you know it's a lot easier
even when you were in the military it
felt good
having your greens on you know having
your bdu on there was something
uh very attractive about having a suit
on not not for the audience just even
for yourself you felt good having a
uniform on i don't know yeah well my i
talked to my father about this years ago
because he always wore a suit when he
was a teacher he's still alive he he's a
teacher and
he always wore a suit and i asked him
why one day and he said because it was
his way of showing respect for the
students
and
i mean i'm not saying that everyone who
doesn't dress in the suit is being
disrespectful but there's something
about
outfitting yourself for the task at hand
and there's also something about
attempting to put some effort into
presenting your putting your best foot
forward and i don't really buy that it
takes more time in the morning argument
it takes a bit more time but once you
like
before i went on this tour i went
through all my clothing and i tossed out
everything that didn't fit and which
included a number of suits that were old
and i had to organize them and that took
about a day to get my closet in order
and
but then it
from then on it only i is actually a
pleasure in some sense do you do it
yourself
do i do meaning like you go through your
closet you do it yourself like pat has a
very unique way of like you don't pack
anymore pat do you like you have someone
no kind of help you out with that
packing is not my strength of my life i
have a lot that's one of my weaknesses
no i still did that for the tour because
i had to figure out what i was going to
wear and but i've had people help me
make clothing decisions let's say now
it's often people who would like to make
suits for me so so i have that as an
advantage and but
i did that pretty much
on my own so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]